Qatar since the moment Qatar was awarded
the World Cup in 2010. people have been
asking how will a country of Less Than 3
million people host a global event
accommodating more than a million fans
the country will soon show the world how
nobody believed that we will be able to
do it nobody expected that we will
achieve all the infrastructure
developments that we did nobody expected
that we will be ready with all the
stadiums that was required in a small
country and in a very confined place in
that small country and we did everything
once their planes touch down organizers
hope fans will experience an efficient
entry process Doha will have two
airports operating to handle the influx
of arrivals from Hamad International
Airport fans can use the Doha Metro on
some lines the trains are capable of
transporting 1 000 people every 165
seconds
between one-third and half of the fans
heading to matches are expected to hop
on a free ride also free shuttle buses
to carry crowds during Peak demand one
of the things to balance this the speak
is that to give The Spectator a multi
multiple options to utilize either the
the Metro the buses the tournament the
tournament buses so they have multiple
options to move around the city Qatar
residents are being asked to drive to
the stadiums to help reduce congestion
on mass transit
one thousand seven hundred kilometers of
Highways and major roads which include
207
bridges in addition to 143 under a
combination underpasses and tunnels
which definitely can you know give the
free flow for a traffic during the World
Cup the Public Works Authority has also
built more than 2100 kilometers of bike
and foot paths five pedestrian
underpasses have been designed to keep
the crowds flowing in what will be the
most heavily trafficked areas
Qatar 2022 organizers say the first
World Cup in the Middle East will also
make history as the first to be carbon
neutral critics say the plan is not
credible but organizers say this is
another opportunity to end the Nay
saying while striving to reduce the
carbon footprint of one of the biggest
sports events in the world Natasha gname
Al Jazeera Doha